Right now, you're
looking at the chilling new video
that we have of Stanislav
Rzhitsky jogging
just moments before he was gunned down.
So you just see him there running.
He's shot and killed multiple times.
Seconds later,
You can see a man in
what appears to be a white hat
trailing him.
Now, it appears that Eric, his killer,
could have tracked his movements
using the popular
running app called Strava.
Now, we have obtained here
at OUTFRONT post of Eric
Skis, two prior runs
to this one where he was gunned down
and murdered from July 3rd and July 5th.
Five days before he was killed.
And look at the map.
Look at the map. Identical.
He takes the same route every time.
And it was along that very same route,
very risky was killed.
Nick Paton Walsh is following
all of these developments
and is OUTFRONT tonight.
And Nick, let's begin
with the breaking news.
This tape that we've obtained
of a Russian general
fired
for speaking out against Putin's war,
senior Russian general
on those crucial front lines
in the south along shop Burisma.
It's hard to overstate
how significant this development is.
Yes, certainly.
And you've got to put it
in the context of the last remarkable
three weeks inside Putin's military.
We've just had the violent armed
rebellion, a mercenary group. Yes.
But essentially fueled
by very similar complaints
about essentially Russia
losing the artillery war
in key front lines, as Yvonne
Popov was making.
Except Popov,
a general, is speaking from inside
Russia's top brass again
about their misconduct
and poor execution of this war.
And he spoken out and he's lost his job
very fast.
Now, this,
I think, is another sign of disarray,
the disarray
which we saw spilling out
after the Viognier rebellion.
And it comes in a really odd 48 hours
for Russia's top brass, where we've seen
high profile assassinations
deep inside Russia,
key commanders killed by missile strikes,
and now this extraordinary dissent
from Popov. Here's what we know
for Russian generals,
a home one
so distant from the front
is no longer safe here.
Former Russian submarine commander
Stanislav Brzezinski
runs his usual route at the usual time,
but with a new, unnoticed companion
on a bicycle.
Moments later, he was gunned down.
Ukrainian Defense
Intelligence said
they had nothing to do with it,
but they knew a lot about it, saying
he had been shot
seven times
with a marker of pistol
and heavy rain meant no witnesses.
Brzezinski commanded a Russian submarine
accused of many attacks on civilians
Ukraine, also said,
although his family
reportedly denied that,
Ukraine added later,
perhaps sarcastically,
that he had been killed by his own men
who refused to kill Ukrainian civilians.
Russia was quick to respond
with their own propaganda,
claiming to have captured the gunman
within hours.
Video We can't verify
but it was a crude bit
to show
they are in control
of the fate of their top brass.
After nine weeks of chaos,
Russian media
said the killing
hinged on a clumsy detail
that Brzezinski had made
his daily run public.
On the running app Strava,
which has a long history
of accidentally
exposing the location of people
who don't want to be found revealing U.S.
military bases in Syria
and Yemen five years ago,
there are the dead
and also the missing News Wednesday, too,
about this key.
Putin Lieutenant Sergei Rivkin
vanished
since he appeared
early in the armed Virginia rebellion.
To plead for it to stop vigorously.
A top Russian lawmaker claimed he was,
quote, resting, whatever that means,
reconstituting the games,
thinking of events and holding notes.
One of the first proposals
for the staff is yet more mystery,
adding to the bigger one.
Where is Russia's
most prominent military figure?
Wagner rebellion leader
Yevgeny Prigozhin.
Not seen since the weekend revolt
Despite Kremlin claims,
he met with Putin days later
and pledged a sudden reversal
and continued allegiance
that jogging or still missing.
A turbulent time in the top brass
are an important two ads
that we've had today
from Russian state
media confirmation
that another key commander again
in the south, Lieutenant General Oleg
Sokolov, was killed.
It seems by a long range missile
that's been blamed by Russian bloggers,
potentially on British
supplied storm shadow missiles.
This, again,
is another commander
for different reasons.
Suddenly not in their post
in the most vital part of the area
which Russia is defending from Ukraine's
continued counter-offensive,
thus picking up pace.
These departures
will have a tactical impact
regardless of how fast
these people are replaced.
Yesterday,
the Russian Ministry of Defense
put a brave face on
saying that volunteers
handed over
2000 pieces of equipment,
tanks, artillery, etc..
But really,
what we're seeing here
is increased dissent
spilling out of the public.
That's exceptionally rare.
It'll damage morale,
but most likely it'll damage
Russia's performance in the very places
they need to fight hardest.